hey david are landslide elections
even possible in the modern united
states
so there's a couple different uh
considerations here
understand that with the electoral
college system
you can have a close popular vote
relatively and a huge electoral college
victory it can happen
you can also have a popular vote win
for one candidate while they actually
lose the electoral college as we have
seen help republicans multiple times in
the last couple of decades including
most recently donald trump in 2016.
the reason in our uh country
that you are less likely to see these
overwhelming
landslide victories right now it's less
about the system the system very much
can allow an overwhelming electoral
college victory
it's more about polarization the entire
country agrees on almost nothing
i imagined when the coronavirus was
starting
this isn't how naive was i what an idiot
right
uh we're not going to politicize a virus
we're going to come together as
americans and we're going to do what
needs to be done and we're going to keep
people safe
and we're going to speak logically and
it's going to be connected to the facts
on the ground
boy was i wrong and if the country
can't even agree barely about
something like a virus so empirical so
fact-based
then it is very difficult to imagine
that you could have
such lopsidedness in the united states
that you would see such an overwhelming
landslide now
that being said how we define landslide
is up to us and you could see this
november
what in the modern era would be
considered a landslide victory for joe
biden
or he might lose or he might lose now
the bigger picture is that um
you have a lot of people in this country
and this gets to critical thinking this
gets to education
this gets to media literacy you have a
lot of people in this country who will
never vote for a democratic candidate
you also have a lot of people in this
country who will never vote for a
republican candidate regardless of their
platform
platforms and regardless of what they
actually stand for um
there are then a bunch of people in the
middle
who will see reason but it is tough
it really requires fixing and changing a
lot of the systems that
keep people in these filter bubbles and
echo chambers
and so when we look at how they are
distributed around the country
that's where the potential for a
landslide really comes when you look at
some of the polling for the upcoming
election and you see
wow trump is only up two in a recent
texas poll from the dallas morning news
wow trump is only winning in missouri by
five whereas he won in 2016 by 19.
demographic changes older voters dying
quite frankly and immigration from latin
america coming in
could actually create a situation where
you know
we've been saying it for a while but it
could be in four years and eight years
and 12 years
texas could be a purple state that
sometimes votes for a democrat
georgia could be a purple state that
sometimes votes for a democrat there are
others
you could actually end up with a
democratic candidate with more than 400
electoral votes
but it will likely take some time the
republican party will fight it with
gerrymandering
they will fight it with voter
suppression because they know they can't
win
on the issues the other thing to
consider is
it's not in the interests of corporate
media to have a blowout election
imagine how many people would tune out
if in june all corporate media said
this race is over and of course they
would never
actually do that but corporate media has
an interest
to keep it seeming as hard fought and
close as possible so
for the foreseeable future what do we
know we know that elections will at
least be portrayed as close
and we also know that unless demographic
changes
overwhelm the level of partisanship that
we have in this country
we are likely to see contested elections
we will put it that way
competitive elections for a very long
time
okay last question today david i see joe
biden has a nice lead
but how can he keep the lead for two
months and prevent it from slipping
away so the numbers are looking pretty
good for joe biden earlier this week we
compared joe biden's polling
to that of hillary clinton exactly four
years ago and we found that
on september 8th which was tuesday joe
biden was up 7.1
compared to hillary clinton being up
only 2.5 on that same date in 2016.
so that's good at this point this
election is going to fundamentally come
down to turn out and foul play very few
people are going to change their minds
between the candidates
in the time that is left i don't want to
pretend that the swing voter doesn't
exist
i don't want to pretend that some people
are undecided as insane as it sounds to
be undecided right now
some people are undecided i'd love to
meet them please call into my show i
want to talk to you but they do exist